- [Instructor] Hello.
In this video, we're going
to think about techniques
for subtracting three-digit numbers.
So let's say we wanted to figure
out what 357 minus 156 is.
Pause this video,
and see if you can
somehow figure this out.
And you don't have to be able to
because we're going to walk,
work through it together,
but it doesn't hurt to try a little bit.
All right, now let's do it together.
And one way to think about it is
what if we were to break up the 156
into its different place values?
So we view it as 100 and 50
and six.
So then this could be rewritten as 357
minus 100,
minus 50,
minus 50, that's five 10s right there,
and then minus six.
Now does this help us?
Pause this video, and see if you can
figure out what this would be.
Well, many of you
probably said, all right,
if I have three hundreds and 57
and if I were to take away 100,
well, then I'm going to be left with 257.
And then if I take 50 away from that,
250 away from 257,
well, I have five 10s here,
and I'm gonna take away five 10s,
so I'm gonna be left with zero 10s.
I'm gonna be left with 207.
And then if I took 207 and
I subtracted six from that,
so 207 minus six,
that, of course, is
going to be equal to 201.
I just took away those six ones,
and I had seven ones on top
of the two hundreds before,
to get us to 201.
So this is one very good technique
for being able to subtract numbers,
and it doesn't just apply
to three-digit numbers.
You could do this with many-digit numbers.
But there's other things
that you could be doing.
You could, for example,
try to adjust the numbers
to make the subtraction easier.
For example, you could say,
hey, wouldn't it be nice
if instead of subtracting 156,
I only had to subtract 150?
And there is a way that you could do that.
As long as whatever you add or subtract
to one of these numbers
you do to the other,
then the difference will be the same.
So there is a situation where
you subtract six from both
of these numbers before you
try to find the difference.
So then let me write this out.
So let's say you wanted to subtract six
from both.
What would this be?
Well, 357 minus six,
well, we're just going
to take six ones away
from the seven ones here,
so it's going to be 351
minus 156
minus six.
Well, that just gets us to 150.
And this might be, for many of y'all,
a little bit more
straightforward to compute.
You might realize, all right,
if I have three hundreds
and I take away one of those
hundreds, I get two hundreds.
If I have five 10s and if
I take away those five 10s,
I'm going to be left with zero 10s.
And if I have one one and
if I take away no ones,
I'm still gonna have one one.
Or you could say, look,
300 minus a hundred is 200,
51 minus 50 is just one.
So that was pretty helpful.
Another technique is to,
instead of going to 150,
you might say, well, what
if I wanted to subtract 160?
Well, in that situation,
you could add four to
both of these numbers.
Add four
to both.
What would happen then?
Pause this video, and
try to figure that out.
Well, what's 357 plus four?
357 plus three gets us to 360,
plus another one gets us to 361.
And if I add four to 156, that is 160.
And since I added four to both,
I added the same amount to both,
the difference is going to be the same.
And so if you look through this,
300 minus 100 is two hundreds left.
And then 61 minus 60, that gets us to,
that gets us to 201.
And what I just kind of
did in my head, if I wanted
to write it out, we could say
this is the same thing as 361
minus 100,
minus 100.
And I could break it out
completely, like I did up here,
or I could break it out partially.
I could just break out the hundreds place
and then break out the 60,
so minus 60.
I guess you could view
that as I broke out the 10s
and I didn't write the ones.
But you can see 361 minus
a hundred would be 261,
and then you take 60 away from that.
Once again, you would be left with 201.
So the big takeaway here is
there's many different ways
to approach subtraction with
however many digits you have,
and this just gets you a
glimpse of different methods.
And some will be more convenient
in different situations
depending on what numbers
you are dealing with.